Oh welcome everyone to the Moses team
nurse sign I'm poppy Peoria Playstation
5 has been announced did you see it what
did you think
don't care as always all that matters is
the memes people were quick to point out
that the design resembles somewhat of a
coat why you have to do it - its
PlayStation vibe
ugly now that's the PlayStation I do
enjoy do-do-do for Smart's looking kind
of hard not gonna oh oh I like to play
with that station if you know what I
mean ah but why do you always do this Oh
what I was a joke now that's kind of
high now that's kind of high PS - yo 5
get it because it looks like pistachio
oh god listen I know you kids won't
understand this but the design to me
just feels like what you thought the
future was gonna be in the future like
wow it's so cool but now it's David it
looks old I don't get it
this I get I understand I'm kidding I
don't marry don't care ugly wife what is
happening I'm not I'm looking at
Playstations damn it's that old meme
with a guy with a big hair I get it now
that's funny dude they should have
dressed him up and he should have came
out dressed like that get it oh no you
know if you get less meme down than Xbox
you thought you thought big-time
you know I kind of want it as a hat I
think we're all thinking the same thing
we all want to wear it as a hat
Sonne can you wear it as a hat please
let us know
sincerely the entire gaming community I
want to wear it as a hang that actually
looks real you see what I mean about the
old depictions of the future do you
understand
Jojo called it as always I knew it I
understand this because I watched the
anime and I am a fan of the anime big
announcement you see what I mean
what were they thinking I actually like
this iteration though what instead of an
AC or a fan or something I have a Wii I
have a doubt their place they should buy
maybe it looks better in person I don't
want to be that guy you know that just
sort of things but before I even saw
anyone's reaction to it I'm like that
looks really ugly I'm not gonna lie what
I am PlayStation 5 no an idiot's and we
should dump get it right you see what I
mean
point proven again I would wear that as
a hat I guess the thing is people you
have to take in consideration is the
value Sony's always been on on the
frontier of cool designs with all their
consoles it might say had a good
suggestion where they they should have
done a new version of the first
PlayStation I feel like that could have
been kind of cool I would rather have
that not gonna lie
with Doug rather have that than this
Middle Eastern looking building okay not
that that anything wrong with the DD DB
DB and the double bill DB damn it look
okay so it looks good in person that's
good bra
excuse me bra it's that a kazoo knee a
i6
hey dude we looking like Sato carbide oh
not gonna lie
fastest things in universe guys count
them with me
light tuck yum what the hell is that
Hawking's radiation rule 34 artist yet
how do you have nothing better to do
just stop
oh yeah they also announced that gta5
Wow
for the seventh year in a row you shown
GTA 5 they always have that one game
that they like okay this game sounds
good so we'll announce it we don't care
Xbox fans playstation 5 weaves don't
mind if I do
can you freak the Xbox I don't think so
when Sony releases places in 5 but
that's what cause what is the prize of
the Sony Playstation it hasn't been
revealed yet a lot of gamers are anxious
599 499 399 you want to play station on
you are two peopie chairs I'll let you
decide we're both know you can get one
chair for one ass-cheek floor game I
call my chair floor that's why we're
still floor game get it get it get the
joke console community freaking out
because the new PlayStation 5 would cost
plus $500 PC users who spend that amount
just for a graphics card what I get
believe it's so expensive I'm on red
unbelievable imagine Karen Webb video
games get cringe can he make coffee
though that's all I want to know Sony
I'll expect a comment very soon so the
starting price for the PlayStation 5
whoops we ran out of time guys didn't
they announce when they announced the
PlayStation 4 the prices is amazing and
they were so proud of it there was no
way that we're not gonna have a part of
that in their presentation so the fact
that they haven't announced the price is
not good news but again what we're all
wondering will it have Skyrim what's the
point otherwise come on Todd give her
Skype give us just give a Skyrim we
don't just get it over with
how old is Skyrim what was that release
this new games existence oh god damn it
what was gta5 early
2013 why do we hear about this still
well well well how the turntables yeah I
can't believe Xbox came out on top with
the help whenever there's ever so
vicious evil troll stirring mean stirs
make fun of a company product you know
someone somewhere it's writing an
article no this is not okay
it doesn't matter guys it doesn't matter
what the PlayStation 5 looks like I
agree with this I definitely don't care
what I put in my living room in front of
everyone I definitely do not care at all
that's probably why they spent millions
and millions on the design because they
it doesn't matter what the design looks
like that's probably why you're right I
am convinced it looks like an air
purifier yeah you know it's not a good
design when literally the mock-ups
looked better
I remember seeing like yeah does this
not look better I would much rather have
this PlayStation five designs Suns with
sleek look we've been waiting for nope
it doesn't look like that it looks like
this what the [ __ ] is that
I would rather have the hit the defecate
version that's the life but still you
understand all right let's look at the
actual announcement I'm curious to see
damn it does have the curves though not
gonna lie I think this is the question
we've all been waiting for which is of
course can you poop in it Sony I'll
expect the common
the team of me review reached out to
Sony for a comment can you poop in it
but they didn't respond oh is that so
funny it's it's always doing this on
this to reach out with these smear
stories they didn't respond
can you poop in it Sony can you why
didn't you respond as you say you can
will it spray water in my zoning huh
always I'll await your response
I'll await now I don't believe me all
right
Dolan darka didn't want to see what he
did
[Music]
Wow Grand Theft Auto 5 for the 519
second diet I do like the meteor mode it
seems like a good idea actually I do
give him credit light
[Applause]
what was that ending it's not a joke
that I did not pick up on it
Sony revealing the PlayStation 5 price
it's coming right up boys hey Gary you
wanna hit the tambourine for me bro all
right at the time bring for me bro yeah
that's my boy oh wait IG do you want to
do that mix me neck neck look in the
camera next name yeah good job all right
what all that means do we have I can
milk you apparently mark said this I
don't know in what context but this is a
meme now hentai artists when a girl has
anything above a b-cup I can milk you
video game companies when they make a
game and it becomes a best-seller this
is literally what I was saying for every
console in existence re-released
remastered game of the year edition game
of the year a year edition remastered
game of the year Assassin's Creed all
copies in one edition have you played
Assassin's Creed I played all of them
all of them on every console yes I am a
gamer reddit when I can milk you meme
gets discovered I can milk you I hug you
how far does it go how far can this milk
stretch itself
meemers when they see an actual good
template I can milk you is it a good
template the future will decide project
managers when they see a competent
developer what the first guy who thought
he could milk a cow must have been like
I can milk you seriously if they think
about a first guy this what was he doing
huh he's like hey look at this better
jam dough something now holy [ __ ]
the stuff coming up brother Jerry Jerry
you gotta see this
Jerry you try it come on
can you imagine of all the things we
probably try to milk as a species and
then finding out it doesn't milk that
sounds like a mr. B's video does it melt
or something I spend 10 grand to milk
see what I can milk you know what I mean
mr. beaks that one's for free just let
me know
star wars exist this mean I can milk you
a will milk you Xbox fans when they need
an argument against X pass notes halo
have you played halo I played all of
them on every single console I feel like
this might be the time for Xbox to
finally catch up on PlayStation I
obviously prefer places because cuz they
always have the better exclusives no
matter what they have that better
experience now it seems like consoles
are becoming more like computers they're
much bigger they're more expensive
they're focusing more and hardware to
try and really push it but Xbox has the
advantage because they're already
integrated with Microsoft so I think if
they focus on that they could have an
aged edge on Sony for the first time I
don't know who knows who cares I don't
next meme I forgot to rate it I rate
this for milk drops
[Music]
now 2020 as we know has not been the
greatest year of all-time
I think that's an understatement
everyone at the start of 2020 everyone
now we've just accepted it this is how
it is now how my parents walk to school
in 1967 yeah well this is how I walk to
school a mom this is normal way to play
up come on the world how are you not in
a civil war yet but you would say I have
no idea honestly please can we just
chill can we just have a Pepsi I'm just
in relax come on let's just chill it out
man since so many weird things are
happening in the world
what did was all a dream what day it was
all a dream no no do not take away anger
this is what happens when things get
canceled online no not big tion guys but
if it was all honestly sometimes I think
that this is true big chunga's may be
better without whatever it was all a
dream
oh no oh so much history's lost fifty
thousand memes used to live here now we
should go so what if it nah not the big
spoon that's my favorite vine he says he
can only have a spoonful and he grabs a
huge spoon don't take that away from me
please please do not what if it was all
a dream me no
[Music]
it was just a joke it was just a joke
we're here I ain't goin anyway you can't
cancel me be another big news came out
this week I think I'm a bit late as
always I mean next meme to two nipple
drops no which is topical because now
Nickelodeon are celebrating pride with
LG Nickelodeon looking at lgbtq+ I can
milk it
who else is gay come on spongebob
spongebob gay now
congratulations Nickelodeon you did it
some people were not surprised by this
y'all just figured out spongebob was gay
Tam's I'd be gay for squid was ass look
at that bra how would we surprise that
spongebob gay when he was literally the
ogia cup things all right I resent that
some people think this is comfortable
that does not make them gay okay
people who think spongebob is gay forgot
that he suffocated himself in the
ultimate sip my new verse Andy I
remember that episode fishy ain't gay so
y'all are gonna call me gay like Patrick
ain't do this people pointed out an
article from 2015 saying that Hilda Berg
reported that I consider them almost
asexual Wow
are you telling me a cartoon for kids
doesn't have to have anything to do with
sex they're responsible shame shame but
then again people pointed out that
people who thoughts bunch of boys gay
years ago people hearing spongebob is
gay now people when they hear he's
actually asexual because he's a sponge
and a cartoon character
apparently asexual counts as LGBTQ plush
so there you have it case solved
spongebob he ain't gay but either way
that's so gay
because respond she's a sponge I think
the main thing to learn from this is
that Squidward has a thick ass at least
that's what I'm gonna take from this i'm
rating spongebob 5 gays
that's it for this week's meme review
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite meme and I'll reply to
some comments become a member live
stream epic only fans account and I see
you guys tomorrow hey go harder bro
so CSV money I'm an ER doc we say it so
hot I get all mushy anima I am Arman
a-bra k'day-bra' we cease my cycle ok
llamando show me your paw you haven't
played tuber simulator on the beach good
pack your bags and sit down no one wants
to see your face max tan lines
anyway download tuber simulator for the
perfect beach body
[Music]